i think if you're starting a media
company and if i started it again
if you didn't go subscription first
you're an idiot and you're a fool
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i
[Music]
all right we're live um so did you see i
uh got ariel helwani to agree to come on
i know good job how'd you do that
a friend a good buddy of mine is like
best friends with him
and
i just begged him
your uh your outreach i had never seen
you try so hard normally you're pretty
cool about things i don't think you
really care with too many people
but i could tell you wanted this one i
did i uh so basically eric for the
people listening there's this guy named
ariel hawani he's
got a million followers on twitter so
he's not like that niche but basically
he's like the god of mma journalism
and the reason why he's interesting is
because he just quit espn where he was
probably making close to a million
dollars a year as a host and he created
a sub stack his own podcast and he's
kind of building like a little media
media empire yep and uh so we'll have
him on and talk about that
yeah and you know the thing that's
interesting about him was
he's been in it for a while so like you
have this phrase i think you've said
like niches get riches basically which
is like yeah
a lot of people are afraid to go into a
niche market
and is it niche or niche by the way i
have no idea
both can work okay good so you know a
lot of people are afraid oh is this too
niche and i think you have the opposite
reaction which is tunish fantastic um at
least that's my my understanding you
tell me if that's that's right or wrong
well it's the the two things one
when you when whenever you start doing
something it's definitely better to
start for a very small group of people
in a very small niche and corner that or
at least get big in that and then expand
or the second thing is you can stay in a
growing niche and grow with but you know
start your start your business on top of
a huge wave for example twitch
video game streaming super small niche
they never expanded really right
it's still the same thing from david
we've tried but
it's still you know dominant where it's
just gaming yeah and that niche has just
they're in it it just is no longer
really a niche or you have like an
amazon only books and then you dominate
that and then cds and then this and then
this and then this so yeah i think
starting small is always the way to go
or is often the way to go
yeah i think in ariel's case what he did
was
um i know he's a fan of i kind of want
to ask him this he's a fan of the nba
like he's a big basketball fan but he
didn't go for journalism basketball
journalism which would have been a more
obvious safe choice instead he went for
mma which was like this fringe really
niche sport that you know it was kind of
like you know john mccain in new york is
calling it human [__] fighting it's like
not allowed in certain places yeah and
so it wasn't really like a very safe
choice but he was the only dude doing it
it felt like it was like you know you
can go back you know 15 years basically
and you see clips of him talking to
people backstage and just budget
production value but he was like the guy
covering this regularly and because of
that he's got like deep relationships
deep respect amongst the fans to the
point where even though dana white who's
the president of ufc
hates him and has banned him from like
ufc events
um he's still the number one journalist
so imagine you know like this guy that
roger goodell the commissioner of the
nfl just hates and bans from the game
still being the number one
you know journalist for for the athletes
that's kind of uh
unusual and so yeah he's an interesting
dude with a cool story yeah i'm excited
to have him i i actually think that i i
think that it's gonna it'll be a hit
with our listeners even the people who
aren't into ufc i think it's gonna be a
hit but
i am a fanboy so we'll see
yeah that's all good can i tell you
about a business that is built on trust
that i'm obsessed with at the moment
okay go for it all right have you heard
of examine.com
no what is examined you've never heard
that okay can you go to your computer
now you have okay i'm at it let me go
there all right so do i tell you what i
see yeah okay i go to examine.com and i
thought it was gonna be about books or
something no it says nutrition
information you can trust
and then it's just like a giant kind of
like google search bar it's like uh like
for example oh it's perfect actually my
trainer was telling me about ashwagandha
i see ashwagandha
i uh i've been taking that for eight
days now
great so it's a supplement and so i go
here and i guess the idea would be
hey there's gonna be a lot of if you
google this you're gonna find a lot of
information but we are a trusted source
we do the research we put the pros and
cons here we make it easy to understand
is that the idea
yeah so i'm gonna i'm gonna summarize
this so the reason this interests me is
i have a friend named seoul s o l orwell
he's a good buddy of mine i've never
even met him but we went to a bunch of
conferences and we were in the same room
and we never met up but we became
friends and um he's a great guy and i
just met him as a guy and then i saw his
business and it's called examine.com and
what it does is they do a few things so
first
they get about 40 000 visitors a day and
they get those visitors by having this
free content so what you're looking at
where it examines that supplement
ashwagandha
but
the model in which they make money is
that they have a membership
that membership has supplement guides
and then they also have a thing where
they look at all the recent studies and
they summarize it to tell you exactly
what you need to know and it'll say this
is a strong study and the conclusion is
this this is a not great study and the
conclusion is this and you shouldn't you
should avoid it and they do that with
all types of studies and basically the
what the company is
and
i'll explain why i think this is a big
deal but basically they take knowledge
that's locked up or complicated to
understand and make sense of it into a
really easy to understand uh way and so
they have i'm gonna give you some stats
40 000 visitors a day 20 employees seven
figures in revenue 50 000 people have
signed up for their membership or um
bought some of their guys and that's
only been around for about two years the
guides have or the membership and so uh
they made money by selling guides and so
i bought this supplement guide they have
one on like
i have like uh panic attack problems
that i'm trying to fix and they have
guides on
it it listed all the it said here if
these six supplements have been proven
by clinical trials to help with panic
attack and it lists them all and it says
take this one if you don't feel anything
in two weeks pair it with this one and
then pair it with this one and they tell
you and they go and when you buy it make
sure that it's magnesium not magnesium
oxalate like they tell you very specific
stuff and i think this business is
amazing it's amazing because they've
spent years building up trust so men's
health
dr andrew huberman do you know who that
is he's that guy who has a youtuber he
talks about health stuff he's like kind
of going viral right now just on joe
rogan and tim ferriss they all saw
everyone's sites examine.com new york
times sites examined.com they've spent
years building up trust every word that
they write is very meticulous now
they're starting to monetize and this
model i actually think it's amazing and
i didn't at first i was like there's no
way this can be a big idea but there's
this company called up to date you've
probably never heard of up to date if
you're listening and you're a doctor you
probably have heard of this and so it's
basically examined.com but for doctors i
mean it's been around before examine.com
so examine.com is that for nutrition
in this business doctors pay i believe
600 a year and they get the same exact
thing they get access to a content
database that very explicitly and
clearly says which clinical trials are
proven which are not and what the
conclusion is and then uh summarizes a
bunch of stuff guess how much money that
makes a year
uh i think a lot i think i think
probably i mean i'm just looking at up
to date and i think it has 15 you know
similar web shows about 15 million
visits
a month so uh that's pretty impressive i
would guess okay i'm going to go high ah
no i'm going to go low it's always fun
to be blown away so i'm going to say 50
million a year
so the estimate is closer to 500 million
dollars a year in subscription
i'm blown away just as i hoped with my
low
because isn't it isn't it shitty when
you're trying to yeah when you're trying
to blow someone's mind and then they
estimate over it you're like well okay
not not that much but it's still cool
it's like god damn goddamn it like you
know that should just be a rule amongst
friends if i ask you to ballpark
something you know let me let me blow
you away and the company that owns this
does the same thing for finance tax and
accounting i believe and that whole
company is publicly traded it does like
5 billion in sales a year
crazy business model and i'll tell you
why this is interesting to me this is
interesting to me because i love content
businesses i love them there's a huge
problem with content businesses which is
they suck at making money if you're
gonna make money in the most traditional
way of banner ads or some type of
buzzfeed style native ads i [__] hate
that this model i love i think that you
could use this model for a bunch of
different
categories including skin care including
beauty i think that would be the next
the the easiest one according to seoul
what do you think about this business
it's pretty neat right
genius yeah uh so up to date makes total
sense uh yeah like i am i'm surprised i
haven't heard of it i am not surprised
something like this exists and works it
just makes all the sense in the world
examine.com also
very very cool and i think sort of like
if if up to date is kind of like a b to
b
examine is kind of like a a b to c where
it's like you know the average person
who's just curious like you i'm curious
about panic attacks i'm curious about
ashwagandha i'm curious about you know
whatever l-carnitine and you know i hear
about it i hear some buzz but i'm trying
to be like smart and safe about things
where do i go that's not just trying to
sell me [__] and not just trying to like
print page views as like a content form
and so i think that trust is uh you know
like sort of like one of the only things
that matters you know like world of
abundance and that's where we are we're
in a world of abundance and so trust is
like one of the key uh these things
and examine.com their rule is they don't
uh recommend any brand so you can't find
any brand on their site if they say take
magnesium oxide i was like sol just tell
me like which brand so i could just buy
it on amazon he goes no we can't tell
you that you got to go and figure that
out because wait for the day we start
doing that is the day we start like
incentivizing the wrong [__] so it's a
pretty amazing business model you know
who else does this is consumer reviews
so consumer reviews you probably don't
use anymore a lot of people who are
younger or my age and younger don't use
it anymore so consumer reviews it's
wirecutter but they charge a
subscription that company it's actually
a non-profit so you can actually look up
their revenues their revenues uh they
charge a subscription revenue
what did i say consumer review consumer
report yeah consumer report it was
around it was a round before wire cutter
i prefer wire cutter now but consumer
report is pretty amazing they charge
subscription revenue they still do like
120 million dollars in subscription
revenue and they're telling you like the
best tv the best microphone the best
computer and they crush it
yeah so let me just uh consumer reports
subscription newsstand and other sales
20 in the year 2020 they did 212 million
dollars in subscription revenue crazy
right
subscription revenue that's insane 245
million overall uh
overall revenue in 2020
insane
i think if you're starting a media
company and if i started it again
if you didn't go subscription first
you're an idiot and you're a fool and
you're a masochist and you like pain
if i if i could do it all over again
knowing what i know now
i would only start that way and it's
totally the i think it's the best
business model clip it uh all right yeah
that's a good one i like that a lot
you've talked about this on like
consumer reports for other things right
so you've talked about it for sas tools
um and then some people have tried that
g2 and and others uh have tried that
what do you think about that what's your
latest thinking on that because you've
been thinking about that idea for a
while i think it's an amazing idea and
someone could still do it g2 has raised
another round of funding uh at like a
multi-billion dollar evaluation i think
i think it still could be done there's a
company called j2 global have you heard
of j2 global
no all right look up the stock of j2
global right now for me i i i act like
i'm setting you up i actually haven't
looked at it in a while
uh is it good
okay so j2 global
um all right it's trading at 130 a share
the market cap is 6.3 billion dollars
and uh
yeah you know like sort of year to date
it's almost double so j2 global what
they do is they own a handful of
publications including i i gn mashable
pcmag
um
offers.com and one or two more but
basically they make the bulk of the
revenue i believe from suggesting which
software to buy in pc magazine and
that's how they make most of their
revenue and it's a publicly traded
company new look it all up so i think
this model can still crush it i think pc
magazine is pretty much garbage g2 is
okay um right but anyway i think it's a
really big business that so many people
are sleeping on and uh you know what
else could you do this sort of trust
trust model for so i have i have one
idea but i'm curious what else comes to
mind for you skin care and beauty that's
what i i think it could be done with
skin care because there's there's an
ocean of there's an ocean of brands
and you kind of care about you know the
problem i think with that is you don't
have fear so there's this one really
good thing about supplements and
medicine is that there's like a fear
component to it right like i don't want
to actually like die or get side effects
from this thing or have a you know sort
of a big problem occur because of the
potential benefits of something whereas
with skin care i think yeah you might
break out or you might just want to know
which one's better
but it doesn't have that fear component
where people are going gonna look it up
and say before i buy this i've really
gotta check and so i think that's one of
the keys um you know there's like which
one of these dishwashers is best i think
that's a consumer reporting it's like i
don't wanna research this like
oh these guys test this for 5 000 cycles
and they tell me which one lasts the
longest and works the best like okay
that's great i was never going to do
that myself um you know i think that's
one version where it's like tires which
tire is the best tire to get which
refrigerator is the best refrigerator to
get and then on the other side there's
the fear one like supplements medicine
sort of like alternative medicines
what's what's gonna happen from those i
think those are two like especially good
categories and i think the difference of
choosing the right category versus the
wrong category is a multiplier of like
10x 10x or 50x of your outcome i i would
imagine you could do the same for
physical therapy so the reason physical
therapy is interesting so basically i've
had a injured achilles for about a year
now and i've been researching like crazy
and if you search
achilles tendonitis there's loads of
different stuff and i've been reading so
many studies and what my conclusion now
is this there's only one way to fix your
achilles tendonitis and that is to do
um well no no it's rest but it's to do
six sets
of 15
achilles like a eccentric drop down so
what that means is you stand on a curb
or a step and you slowly let yourself
fall and then you uh kind of step up and
then slowly and if you do that and i
read
study after study it's almost like been
unanimous that if you do this for three
months every single day your achilles
tendinitis will get better and i had to
dig so deep for that and i think that
something like this could exist for
physical therapy and injuries and things
like that right yeah
yeah i i kind of agree with you right
now my mom has this like she had vertigo
but then it kind of went away but she
still feels symptoms and the doctor's
like uh you don't have vertigo she's
like no no i get that but what do i have
i have something this is not right and
they're like
uh blood work looks fine
and then she has to call back like hey i
know the blood work looks fine but i'm
not right yeah what do i do they're like
ah go to let's do an mri same thing and
then it's like finally okay do these
like do this physical therapy so she
literally walks around the house with a
piece of paper in front of her that has
like a letter on it so her eye has to
focus on it and she moves it to the
right while she's walking and then moves
it to the left while she's walking
dude is this the exercise like maybe it
is if it is fantastic but where how do
we know that this is it and that there's
not like a much faster better way
because previously when she had vertigo
um that was like vertigo proper she went
to three doctors and nobody knew what to
do the fourth doctor was like oh lay
down and he like shook her head like
vigorously and it's like this known cure
and basically like loosens up the
crystal in the inner ear or whatever and
she was like fixed in 10 minutes and
she's like wow like if i just hadn't
come to see you
how many more months or years would i
just had vertigo that's like a pretty
scary thought
yeah i think that could work or here's
another thing do you know ky you know
anything about chiropractory
i know i know what most people know
which is like uh skeptical skeptical
hypo eyes as our boy brandon chomp says
and i didn't know that i thought sorry
to chiropractors or chiropractors uh
fans out there but basically
chiropractor
it was invented by a guy i forget his
name but he was like a snake oil
salesman he was full of [__] and he
thought that like
i'm gonna someone's gonna correct me
because i'm kind of getting it wrong but
basically like there's like evil spirits
or something in you and if you just if
you adjust the spine it releases it now
some chiropractor like can help very
little like but ninety percent like
ninety percent of what chiropractors
what we think they do you
you can't adjust your spine and like
your headaches stop like that's just not
how your body works but it's nonsense
right also the the acceptance rate of
chiropractor school is a hundred percent
so like and it's like it's like it's
like a google adsense certification it's
not like you know what i mean
i know i'm gonna get flack for this and
yes there are some chiropractors out
there a lot of it though is nonsense and
i i think an examine.com can exist for
all types of parts of the body so anyway
that's my idea on xamarin.com i thought
it was interesting i'm a bit obsessed
with it i'm currently on a vitamin
regimen and i discovered it on there i
thought it was cool you want to do
another one
yeah okay so let me give you another
trust as a service so this is just like
a i'm calling this my two dollar blue
collar side hustle right now which is
here's a side hustle that will make you
some bucks it's not going to be a huge
business probably it's not even maybe
going to be around five years from now
but i think right now it's a thing you
could do so um
are you big on did you order a lot of
food because i'm a door dasher right
like i am i do but not but not like you
you do like every meal
well i i got a chef now but even with
the chef there's still you know two to
two meals a week where i'm like let me
just fire up the door dash and see what
happens dude it's so expensive it hurts
me and so when when you get your meal
they all have this like sticker on it
now that says safety sealed and it's
just all it is is like you know normally
it's like in a bag and they would like
tie the bag in a knot and now they like
sticker it to show like no human like
the food went in and then we sealed this
[__] because there's like viral videos
of like door dashers eating the food
eating food coughing in the food i don't
even know what the fear is it's just
like
i can't lie when i see the sticker i'm
like good i'm glad they sealed it like
good i'd rather be sealed than not
sealed that's for [__] sure and there
wasn't even a thing i was thinking about
before but somebody is out there selling
branded
safety seal stickers to restaurants and
i just think that in general there's
gonna be a whole wave if you just said
i'm gonna sell trust and safety as a
service
i'm going to sell it to every business
that needs to reassure its customers
that it is taking coveted safety
protocol seriously and then you can you
can dial that knob up to level 12 of
like chiropractory where you're like i'm
just gonna mail these to everybody they
yeah put it on your self honor code this
is honor code system you know like just
just put this sign up in your in your
restaurant uh put this mat on the
outside of your thing put this on every
door knob hang this on every doorknob uh
you know stick put the sticker on every
cup you know whatever um
you could just send it or you could
actually like go out and verify and say
hey here's our five point you know
safety inspection and we send mystery
shoppers out or whatever we like
actually create kind of like a zagat
reviews
type of of sticker or seal of approval
specifically for trust and safety around
covid that's the general idea what do
you think
i love it and i'm gonna show you an
example of of something similar to this
have you heard of uh i think it's
pronounced lead l-e-e-d
leed certified the like green buildings
thing
yeah so i was looking this up so it's a
non-profit so you could easily see their
sales so that that wow they do uh i
think this is i i'm almost positive it's
run by a company called the u.s group
it's not a company but a nonprofit u.s
green building council and i think they
is that it do you know
no but uh yeah i believe you
and they do 31 million dollars a year in
sales and basically i have no idea what
the
i have no idea why buildings are
incentivized to do that but i imagine
the business model is such where you pay
led lead i guess is what is what it's
called and oh here dan says he's a
former accredited professional for lead
so
okay on a scale of one to chiropractor
where is lead certification
it's nowhere near chiropractor it's
legit
and uh you are a lead accredited
professional what the heck does that
mean did you pay for the first did you
pay for this accreditation my company my
former company did yeah okay so somebody
paid for you to get certified and then
you charged other companies to go give
them the stamp of approval is that right
yeah so as a professional you get like
one point towards the point total you
need to become a lead building and then
there's like a
silver gold platinum scale and it's [__]
like you know you use the right kind of
light bulbs you use the right kind of
insulation that sort of thing when
you're building your building right or
renovating yep stuff like that um air
quality indoor air quality which is
really bad normally
low use water things like that no smoke
you sound like a lead professional right
now bro i feel like i'm getting lead
certified as we speak
why does the building care about getting
lead certified look good that's a good
question yeah i think it's a little bit
of uh just wanting to be green
but there's no incentivized
incentivization dude
the government does the government like
give you anything or is it simply just
for branding and awareness
i don't know it's been 15 years since i
took the exam so i'm uh a little out of
pace on it but i'm not sure if there's a
big incentive for it dad how old are you
i'm 35. you did this when you were 20
you were a 20 year old lead certified
might be around a little bit i think i
was 22 when i took it okay
um more importantly i got a lead
certification go to my twitter profile
real quick just see what you see there
dude [__] that i think you're the worst
that is so lame
so did you be verified so lame are you
kidding me john got verified
he's got a blue check mark i think that
is the lamest dude you are not one
you're not a man of the people anymore
you're so out of touch
i'm used to [__] on uh ah i don't need
that i don't need that
you know what what does that mean
anyways
who cares about that anyways you know i
actually prefer not to ha and now that i
have it
all that all that [__] is out the
window i am so glad
why did you get it so glad i got the
blue well i got it for like actual legit
reasons like first i was just i wanted
it for my ego for many years when i was
you know whatever didn't happen who
cares
but then people started actually like uh
impersonating me and scamming my
followers so they were all these
accounts get created every month and
they would go dm my followers like hey
yeah what's up and people like oh hey
thanks for the dm
like no problem you know i saw you
follow me um
you know what are you doing with your
portfolio lately and they would scam
them into either
sending them crypto or buying random
crypto [__] coins or they were um
getting them to like buy stocks or like
send them like send them money to go
like invest in their like they like
pretended they were my fund and so
people were actually like you know it
used to just hurt my feelings that i
wasn't verified but then it was actually
like hurting other people and so i was
like dude what the [__] i was bitching
about it yeah and uh i get i get that
prize
i get that but that's the only reason
i'll accept
i think every other reason is [__] i
don't i think they're stupid what's that
it's a little jealousy i'm smelling i i
don't know like
i think you kind of want the blue check
mark too i think the people on twitter
twitter need to help you out i think i'm
i think i'm barely famous enough to get
it but
i i will not get it i'm not you have
crypto
tell me right now you push a button and
you could just have it or not have it no
no nothing else just push this little
key on your keeper you tell me you
wouldn't push that button
i give you my word i will not push that
button wow but
but if i am not
if i end up having scams like you then
yes but i've not had that i've not had
that problem yeah it became like a legit
problem uh anyways so okay lead
certification so yeah basically i think
i think lead is another good one like
i would love if somebody just took on
lead
and just called it like you know green
home
oh you oh you're you're a green home
triple star wow
[Laughter]
doesn't that sound good already yeah and
like again you could turn the knob
however like you can go super legit if
you really like
find ways that you could kind of score
buildings um or you could like be
somewhere in the middle and you know
build scam but like dude i would do that
trust as a service is a great business i
actually think that the health
department's scorecard is [__] so i
had a hot dog stand i mean duh uh i
talked about that you told that story
yeah yeah you know i don't drink either
um
and uh when they when they did my health
certificate certificate like i just
bullshitted through it like hardcore and
like i mean my [__] was clean but like
they had all these boxes we had to check
and it was [__] but in the day that
we were doing it i actually was wearing
flip-flops and they gave me a 95 instead
of a hundred
and so like i think it's kind of not
gross toes out while you're making hot
dogs yeah nobody wants we're outside in
100 degrees selling meat that's been
sitting there for like you know what i
mean like forever like it's it's [__]
disgusting anyway
it is super just i worked so without my
first thing was a sushi restaurant and
we had a comment we worked out of a
commissary kitchen which is like a it's
a central kitchen where
like caterers and bakers it's like a
kitchen without a storefront so in there
was all the food truck guys and so you
so in that i saw the hierarchy of like
degeneracy it's like caterers okay so
like bakers bakers are good people
bakers are nice women who uh care about
their product and they do a great job
and they're very hygienic and then
caterers are like kind of like they're
like bakers they're they're legit but
you know the the neat the demands on a
caterer are so high it's always high
urgency they're preparing for a 200
person party or whatever so you know
they're kind of get [__] done they'll
cut through the red tape but you know
you you respect their decisions
then there's the [__] food truck guys
food trucks guys
they think this is a bar they're just
drunk while they're prepping their tacos
they're pretty disgusting and then you
have the hot dog guy at the end this guy
straight up okay so there's like a sink
and if you don't know what a three
compartment sink is you haven't paid
your blue collar dudes but basically a
three-compartment sink is like kind of
where you do the dishes in a commercial
kitchen
and like the three three compartment
sink is just literally it's full of like
the dirtiest dishes
and just a chemical bomb you put in
there to like clean them and the [__]
hot dog guy in our comfort kitchen would
just go and he'd just fill up the sink
with the hot dogs that he's gonna be
selling like three hours later he'd just
be throwing the hot dogs around there
washing them dry you know put them in
the other sink to dry off and it's like
this guy there was zero and i literally
i don't think i've had a hot dog since
uh because i saw how the sausage was
made and i you know never want to see it
again so that's my public service
announcement don't eat me yuck
i agree i was clean i mean i kept myself
clean but i can see why most don't you
can get you don't have to you can just
get away with it it's not even counting
what's the meat i'm not like forget the
meat let's say the meat was pure the way
it's handled disgusting so i think you
could build a new version of
of a health department score actually i
i actually think that's legitimate how
many other can we just do this like okay
i'm bullshitting about twitter right now
could you just do this where it's like
you have a con you have like a content
score like you know just like how uh you
know either like how like you know uh
safe and kind of like non-offensive your
content is like maybe it's something
that's like
you know it's around your cancellation
you know what we should do you know
interestingness or your fan score like
how much your fans care about you are we
just [__] like your engagement score
but we make it really visible it's like
sam he may not have the most followers
but his followers love him it's like we
make your q score yeah you know what qq
is it's like a popularity ranking uh we
just make some
it's oh you haven't heard this q score
it's like a thing for celebrities
yeah it's a thing for like a hollywood
celebrity it's like what's your what's
your popularity kind of like it's not an
approval rating it's like your
popularity rating how how well do people
know you and like you know obama has a
high q score
and oh yeah i feel like you could do
that on social media with clout but just
like [__] the whole thing
yeah i i i think that's crazy and i
think that's good klout score i actually
think clout was amazing so clout was a
company that was around it was spelled
k-l-o-u-t
uh they had like a hundred employees
they raised a lot of money they ended up
selling for a hundred million dollars i
think it was like a hundred million
dollars of stock in a privately held
company like i don't think it was
actually that kind of an exit but they
um
great idea clout early you were just too
early amazing idea way too early amazing
idea if it were around now it would be
the best
somebody restart clout and just dm us i
thought it was it was a great branding
and people still to me make jokes about
clout like they'll be like oh i got to
create that cloud score i know what
they're talking about i had a cloud
score and basically what happened i mean
my cloud score wasn't that great i had
like five thousand friends on facebook
though and so i qualified and so maybe
the fact that you're justifying it shows
how good of a hook this is how much i
would use it all the time mcdonald's
would send me a five dollar gift card
once a month right um yeah like amazing
it was it was so cool i loved clout so i
think that could exist and i think that
could that could kick ass um i think
this is like yeah i think there's a lot
of time
i don't even think you really need to do
that much differently right like there's
i'm sure there's like 20 of things you
would tweak uh maybe in the execution
like you know maybe you don't have to
raise that much money
i think the timing is the biggest tweak
that you needed to make maybe you change
the way it's calculated or the way you
promote it or the business mod whatever
i don't think you need to change that
much i just think that the time the time
is now and like as donald trump
basically created this thing called fake
news i think fake news is very
underrated how like big of a wave that
actually was created how much distrust
there is around around brands and
entities now and so people are kind of
like the atomic unit of a brand at this
point and so yeah i think that uh that
cloud cloud should be remade how about
the fact that so hubspot has a hub so
this one woman who works with me just
got scrum certified and we paid five
grand it was five thousand dollars or
four thousand dollars and i'm like so
scrum i i don't even know what it is i
guess it's just like a um a project
management uh yeah that's how you manage
like engineering sprints yeah and we
paid five grand and i was like who the
heck like is the scrum like decision
maker and then i realized hubspot
scrum master by the way is it really oh
my god it's much more like legit that it
probably really is hubspot has hubspot
certification courses and if you look on
people's linkedin they they brag about
passing hubspot certification courses we
gotta talk i gotta talk to us i'll be
like how did i'm like look like you guys
are amazing and wonderful and legit but
like you weren't always amazing
wonderful and legit you were just
starting out and you somehow convinced
people to trust you and take this
seriously right how on earth did you do
that because that's amazing so they paid
hubspot so the so hubspot is the
collector of the 5000 dues for the scrum
training
no sorry
there's a different organization that
does scrum but hubspot you've never seen
people brag about their hubspot
certification so like if you google
hubspot search certification they've got
like these classes
people if they tried to brag to me about
that so so
that's an immediate block so there's
like inbound sales hub stop marketing
software inbound marketing and if you
google people if you google like that
and linkedin there's so many people that
put that on their linkedin like
certified in
uh
whatever like there's so many people
that cite
uh hubspot as their thing and so like
and so they put it like you know how
like one time if you look up tyra banks
on linkedin she probably still does this
she puts that she graduates from harvard
okay she went to a harvard
exact
executive learning day
and people probably
yeah it's like a two day
look at look at if you look at tyra
banks
okay okay okay so she did a nine week uh
program for executives called the the
owner president management extension
program yeah dude harvard makes it
unbelievable i'm going to break this
down actually next podcast harvard's
kind of whole business model around
online programs harvard business review
the media company i'm gonna break that
whole thing down because it's crazy i'll
do it with you i've studied the business
review a bunch um all right can i tell
you about another another idea or a
person actually yeah all right there's
this guy named matt uh how do you
pronounce his last name
from uh
which or whatever uh man i don't want to
butcher this guy
mick
sorry matt i like you i just don't know
how to say your last name make him like
mickey
and then with the wicks at the end
mickey weeks all right mickey wits
i've known about this guy for a long
time but i'm gonna tell you everything
that he's done because i bet you you
know all of his work but you maybe
didn't know he was the one behind it so
in 1998 when he lived in australia he
started this company while he was in
high school called sitepoint sitepoint
basically is a publisher of books
courses and articles for uh developers
and so you can like learn html css java
ruby all that they've never raised any
funding and they have like 50 employees
i imagine if i had a bet they'd probably
make five to ten maybe five to 15
million dollars a year um that's my
guess um
well how do you spell it
mitscovich mizkovich his name is matt
mcmiskowicz um have you heard of
sitepoint sitepoint.com no is that still
around all right it's still around and
so like i've heard his story he was like
basically i started this like as a forum
and then a blog and people would come to
my forum and blog and i was taking like
10 000 advertising checks when i was
like 17 high school so i dropped out of
high school and went all in on this then
when he went all in on it his forum on
sitepoint people were buying and selling
businesses on it and so he spun out one
of the the forums into his own business
called flippa you've heard of flippa
right yes
so i believe that prolific he's got
really proud because you haven't even
got the two of his hits listen so we
started flippa which is a marketplace
for buying and selling smallish websites
and stores and and things like that
they've got millions of users flippa is
like not micro acquires in the space but
flippa is like considered like the thing
and in fact i think they just raised a
little bit of funding like 20 million
dollars recently it's got hundreds of
employees it's a pretty big business
third
on sitepoint he also discovered that
people in the forum were uh
um
buying and selling designs and so he
started this thing called 99 designs
which is amazing 99designs is one of the
best sites that i've used it's a great
place to you basically you own 99
designs you give them a thousand dollars
you tell them what you want and like a
hundred designers give you a mock-up of
what they think that your project should
look like and then you pay for you
select the one you like and they get the
money so they've they do close to 100
million i believe in revenue they raised
45 million dollars in funding okay from
there he also saw that people were
hiring all types of devs so we started
hired.com hired.com i think it kind of
fizzled out a little bit it might still
be around it's definitely around but it
kind of fizzled a little but they raised
132 million dollars in funding
definitely could still be quite big so
that's pretty amazing then he now his
next thing is he's creating and so this
is all has to do with site point he
started site point 1998 his next thing
is called unstoppable domains you know
what that is i bet you know that is
better than i do go ahead
yeah it's just a way to buy uh buy
domains in crypto so like i have a
domain that ends instead of dot com it
ends in dot eth which is dot eth right
so it's a it's a domain name service
like uh it's a domain domain i think
it's a registrar this is a domain
registrar for making crypto domains and
the reason it's called unstoppable
domains is because
when you own that namespace nobody it's
on the blockchain nobody can sort of
take it away from you nobody can switch
the rules on you um it is sort of there
forever so this guy matt uh mitkovic has
done it i don't think he started by the
way i think he joined it which is i dm'd
and when he joined it
because i was like if if the guy who's a
founder of all these successful
companies joins a company it's like one
of the strongest signals that there
could be um like just recently uh i was
saying this about uh my my friend has
got david macintosh he started
tenor it's a it's a gift keyboard sold
it to google for i think a couple
hundred million dollars and then he
joined instacart as like one of their
execs so you know like any time you're
you it's like this person's
independently massively wealthy has they
want to start their own company and they
if they want to join as like not even
like join his number one he wasn't
joining a ceo didn't join a cto just cpo
he was like you know maybe like in the
top 10 of the insta work execs so that's
when you know like oh [__] this is like
uh there's a jugger or not that's the
this person thinks this is a 100 billion
dollar company if they're doing that
that's crazy to me
so and there's guys let me just tell you
so i dm'd and i go you join unstoppable
super interesting move i said what makes
you bullish on it here's what he said
i'm just going to read it out loud
may or may not mean anything he goes
there's a trillion dollar asset class
which is basically domains that people
are navigating using the equivalent of
an ip address if web encrypt if web3 and
crypto is here to stay
then building the identity like the the
basically the address for consumers is
one of the most important companies of
the decade
that he's like in the normal
normal web you have icann you know what
icann is
it's not yeah so it's like a it's like a
it's like a committee which it's kind of
[__] to me but it's the committee
that decides [__] about the internet
what domains can be you know can you
have a dot photo or dot biz yeah uh
domain like i can kind of decides those
types of things he goes it's one of the
oldest monopolies on the internet it's
begging to be disrupted crypto gives us
a way to disrupt that because it's
creating like a new a new ground where
they don't have jurisdiction they don't
have rule of law over there um
that's one of the few crypto examples or
blockchain examples where i
wholeheartedly agree and i think that's
actually incredibly useful and totally
right i don't know who's going to host
the domain or like how that works but i
agree with that like idea because if if
you're doing something i can or whoever
can can pull it
right
um
yeah anyway so
uh so then he was just telling me a
little bit more about it but i was like
yeah that's that's great that's cool and
i saw i bought an unstoppable domain
this guy is amazing so um and get this
he's 37.
he's only 37 years old
amazing this is a have you you've heard
of him people don't really yeah people
don't really know about this guy like or
they don't really talk about this guy
but he's it's a pretty prolific career
and he's kind of like
independent and definitely like a um
he's an independent thinker i could tell
right because 99 design is actually a
pretty like very novel mechanism it's
like oh what if we created kind of like
a design auction right it's the best
it's the best like we used it for our
podcast thumbnail or our cover photo yes
podcast we did gone through 99 designs
and check this out when we did it
hubspot
um like had all these designers work on
this stuff and they made like some
pretty good logos and but we still went
with uh this guy in the philippines who
made this logo and it was even it was
better than all of them the the
trends.co website i had designed on
there because like you know like when
you work with a designer you don't want
to be rude to your own designer be like
no this sucks can you just do exactly
what i told you to do please
but you can do that with a freelancer a
little bit more than a full-timer so i'm
a fan of 99designs and by the way it
looks like there's this guy mark who is
his co-founder because it says
co-founder of nine indesign's flippa and
sitepoint so it's like that's pretty
cool i like when people create this kind
of like duo it's like yo let's just
build a bunch of companies together i
find that to be like pretty inspiring uh
and it tells you something about how
somebody is to work with if somebody
wants to keep going back in and
work with you again and i've talked to
this guy i actually invited him to
hustle con two or three different times
and
he committed and then some scheduling
stuff happened and we weren't weren't
able to make him make it happen but i've
talked to him on the phone he's very
humble
so uh i'm a big fan of this guy
yeah me too um okay so he's kind of like
our our little you know internet founder
of the week i don't know we need a name
for that that uh we had the billy of the
week we got the blue collar side hustle
we need something for just founders who
are badass who have done like yeah
serial
serial entrepreneurs
yeah this guy's great um all right you
wanna you wanna do one or two more uh
yeah let's do some other ones okay so
um do you know this company guthy ranker
i bet you know about it and i bet i can
tell you
tell me all about so last night all
right so i've been on this i've been on
this binge i gotta say i've been on this
binge
um
i i'm rereading the book that really got
me
into
being like kind of like a startup
founder can i guess can i guess yes
think and grow rich
no but that is a good guess especially
if that's what we're talking about i
actually haven't read that book so i'm
gonna i want to read it now after
reading about guthrie ranker but um
i
i'm rereading f four hour work week so
uh your bud tim ferriss um
wrote this book i got it right when i
was starting my first company so i
started my company before this but once
i started reading it i was like oh wow
this there's people that are like me
that are out there who think this way
and this guy's got like systems about
this i'm just i just started figuring
this stuff out this guy's like been
doing this for a decade great and i got
what you call the four hour fever which
is what happens right after you read the
book uh it's my own term because i i've
given this book to maybe 50 people since
and they all get the four hour fever
right after i infect them with the book
and um
we already lived the four-hour work week
so now we live it and so i'm whipped
back and i'm re-reading it right i'm
like okay i'd rather yeah i want to
reread the classics and so i went back
and rereading it and i just want to see
uh you know
what of it do i still believe in what of
it do i disagree with what's changed
anyway it's pretty interesting i'm
taking a ton of notes and i texted you
this while i was reading it i go
let's write a best-selling book
10 million copies sold
the next four hour work week and then
you're like okay easy
and i was like all right perfect
um because i'm serious about that i'm
like obsessed with this so i've just
been writing content i've been writing
and i've been reading all weekend long
like i've just been binging like i'm up
till four in the morning every night
doing this and i'm like pretty convinced
that we could put out like an amazing
amazing book so anyways that's like you
know just calling my shot
um gonna do that well don't be surprised
we're gonna use well i want to be
involved let me let's go i i invited i
wanted to do i'm like i'm doing this
either way but i was like what would be
the best i go
what if the best writer i know partner
with me on this and we trade it off
chapters so like i can say something
i'll write a chapter and what i want you
to do is basically i want you to read it
and then you write what you would write
right after you read that so it's like
uh you know like actually i totally
agree with sean with this one i have my
own story of how i did that or
disagree i do it totally differently and
i just think that if we play off of each
other a little bit it can become a very
interesting book because there's not
many books that are out there that are
like that that may all change but that's
what's in my head i also think that we
should do there's one book that had a
pretty fundamental change in my outlook
and it's called founders at work and it
was by jessica livingston the woman who
started uh
y combinator with uh paul graham their
husband and wife and basically it was
just interviews but for some reason it
was really special and it was just
interviews transcribed i think we could
do just interviews and write our
analysis and reply to the interviews and
we i read that book on a plane i still
remember it because there's a chapter in
there about hotmail
and i just remember reading that book
and being like this is awesome this is
what is this what it's like to start a
company or be around people that start
companies this is [__] awesome and
you know by the way i hope this podcast
ends up being that for some number of
people in the world but that could be
our first book if you want because
that's like a pretty easy and actually
amazing and could be fun
i don't even care on the details i i
just know
10 million copies sold best seller for
some people this is their version of for
our work what for our workers what's for
me i want this to be that for like a
whole you know a million people out
there i think that would just be amazing
so let's talk about gun three raker can
i tell you what i know and you could
tell me if it's true or not yeah explain
them i i did a deep dive on them last
night so uh all right
let's fill in gaps all right so they are
a
marketing and ip owner so they own like
a it's a business that markets other
stuff they mostly don't develop their
own products but they buy products or
they license them um it's started by a
guy named steven gunthri is that his
name there's a guy one of his last names
gunthy guthy guffey not guppy and then
the other guy's last name is ranker so
that's and they
and they started i think as early as the
early 80s they're in marketing and they
basically bought infomercials and one of
the first big hits was they bought the
rights to the book thinking grow rich
and they created infomercials and direct
response copywriting ads that they put
in magazines and they sold shitloads of
this book like millions so then they
just
repeated and then they eventually bought
proactive they own proact they own
proactive and they own a bunch more they
probably do a bill north of a billion in
sales and they do the same type of model
go ahead so it's an infomercial it's a
direct response company which basically
they made their name by doing
infomercial based sales
and they do about
between one and a half to two billion in
sales a year they own brands that you've
heard they they they brought brands to
market that you've heard of like
proactive also tony robbins his kind of
personal power or like audio books um
thinking grow rich so okay so here's
kind of some of the cool stuff i i found
out about them okay so how did it start
one of the guys i think guthy he had
started a company and this is how funny
the world works and why really all you
gotta do is just get in the game and
start making [__] happen because
nobody could have predicted this path
right so he starts a company that just
does audio cassette production so like
uh copying so like you have a cassette
you want more copies of that cassette
send me the send me the original
recording i'll make you a bunch of
copies so it's basically like this guy's
a [__] like kinkos right like it's
just like a printer uh for audio
cassettes and he gets this order and
this guy says hey i need 200 to 250 oh
sorry i don't know why i said that this
is a small number
basically the guy wanted almost almost
100 000 cassettes made he goes 100 000
what are you making and um you know it
ended up being 50 000 copies of a
cassette that was about real estate
about how to make money doing real
estate investments
and he's like wow this is that's amazing
and he looked up the company and the guy
was selling through infomercials
so he goes to his buddy uh ranker and
ranker at this time i think had
his family owned like kind of like a a
resort like a tennis resort or something
like that so i think it could probably
come from a good family so he goes hey
dude this guy ordered for me 50 000
copies of this cassette it's amazing
forget making cassettes like let's do
this infomercial thing that must be
amazing and so they go okay what are we
going to do we need a product and so
they that's when they were like hey
what's up what's something we're both
into it's like they both had made their
bones they both really loved this book
think and grow rates so that's when they
went bought the rights to it for a
hundred thousand dollars
they ended up making 10 million dollars
in the next three years off of sales of
think and grow rich right they basically
bought the right something to grow rich
and they produced this infomercial they
hire this football player frank
tarkinton to do it they go and i by the
way i watched the full 30 minute
infomercial last night at four in the
morning i'm like
i'm like watching this thing and
you can find it on youtube and it has
875 views on this video and basically
it's this infomercial and it starts with
like
um
this production and it's basically like
these people it's kind of like
testimonials but they don't tell you
what the product is it's like
you know i always wanted to just own my
own business i was so tired of working
for somebody else
and then finally i felt like this is the
solution broken down into tactical steps
but they don't tell you the name right
and then it's like an interview with the
founder of domino's he's like i never
went to college i had the lowest gpa in
my high school class
but i read this book and afterwards you
know like it became my blueprint for how
i started dominos and like it's like
it's like what's the book what so they
just get you like salivating what's the
book and then three minutes and frank
tarkik comes on he says
you know the richest people in the world
andrew carnegie and the rothschilds and
whoever else like all these people our
andrew carnegie commissioned this guy to
go study what the most successful people
on earth the ross childs and others were
doing and he went and he interviewed all
of them and he packages and he packaged
all that that knowledge and wisdom into
a book that's been a bestseller for
years it's the book that executives say
is their secret weapon blah blah blah
it's just like so it's like such a hard
sell but that's like what infomercials
are it's like once you get in you're
like all right i'll bite what is it so
yeah like [__] it i'll order the thing
and so that's how they sold think and
grow rich it's kind of like an amazing
information i recommend you go watch it
if you're kind of like a marketing
person by the way they bought that in
1988 so 100 grand is the equivalent of
is this true only 225 000 so it's only
2.2 x
um
and when they uh
well the takeaway here should not be
like i can't do that nowadays but
actually the if you look at the
infomercial and if you go and if you
google like guthrie raker infomercial
breakdown or if you just go and make
your own and you look at
you break it down and you like copy it
word for word and you break down the
sections and you apply that section to a
sales letter right now
it 100 will continue to work right
like if you see their infomercial like
the ladies are gonna be wearing like
1980s clothes and the guys will have
weird haircuts you're like oh my god
it's so old
no it will continue to work and tv
infomercials at the time was like dirt
cheap so they were babe when they did
the thinker girl which they just bought
tv space in six small tv markets and
like you could buy the midnight slot the
2am slot and these are basically like is
essentially free they needed some
programming to fill air time and so
these started out really really cheap
now it's gotten much more expensive
right so like let's take proactive i
think proactive at its heyday or you
know kind of like some you know this
maybe 10 year old data at this point but
they were spending about 250 million
dollars a year just on the media buying
so just on the infomercial space
and then they're spending
like because if you go if you watch a
proactive thing it's like justin bieber
was their like signature person right
because proactive was basically saying
hey teens you don't need you don't have
to have acne you can get rid of your
acne this way and justin bieber was like
you know the teen idol with great skin
and so it was like uh justin bieber and
adam levine and like you know the maroon
5 guy like there's all these people
right britney spear i don't know who
else it was but they would get paid five
to ten million dollars to appear in a
proactive infomercial like crazy money
for for an influencer like that's a big
influence or spend and so this is just
influencer marketing
done like at level 12 as i like to say
right like what is that what is the
maxed out version of this proactive is
the maxed out version of it and so they
own like a bunch of brand they own like
glow by j.lo it's like you want jlo skin
by j.lo's glow then it's like oh you
want uh this other supermodel skin buy
her thing it's like very much around
skin care because that i guess is like
one of the like
you know that's like the sweet spot of
like price big market and celebrity
endorsements go a long way the two big
niches are fitness or i would say three
skin care fitness self-help so like tony
robbins became like a household name
using this on the self-help side on the
fitness side they had a bunch of
different brands and then beachbody took
the same playbook and they created p90x
and the beachbody program using the same
same idea they became competitors
there's a guy i'm trying to think of
what what's it called it's called uh
mind something i'm trying to look it up
but basically there's a guy it's not
mind body but it's similar to that word
i can't remember what it was mine valley
you knew exactly mind
i was talking about there's a guy like
the philippines or thailand or i don't
know where they're based yeah there's
some
i don't want to be disrespectful but
there's some weird stuff going on with
this company i don't know what the truth
is but basically if you look at this
company mindvalleymindvalley.com
he does this now and basically this
company what they do they probably do 50
million a year in sales and what they do
is they buy programs from people so they
have one called life book one called om
ombana i think that's a
yoga thing and then they have ever coach
which is uh i actually don't know what
some of these services are but they have
a bunch of these and what they do is
they find people who have like a yoga
course or
some type of program on so they have
programs on sleep they've got programs
on yoga on uh meditation health wellness
and hippie dippy [__] you know it's like
a combination of like very legit to like
uh you know like tantric astrology or
whatever you know like it could be
anything and they're experts on
long-form copywriting which is basically
an infomercial and they're really good
at buying traffic and they make tens of
millions of dollars a year in revenue
all bootstrapped and so if you want to
look at the internet version of this
there's also agora which is a 1.5
billion dollars and another version of
this is uh we have a guy named craig is
craig clements we had a guy named craig
clemons his business is called golden
hippo they own i think eight or nine
brands and i think if i remember
correctly didn't he say they do like mid
nine figures in revenue yeah i think i
think gold and hippo or our buddy craig
company i think it's on par with guthrie
ranker
um in terms of like sort of like success
uh i i think other record does does over
a billion in sales so you know it's it's
the next level but golden hippo is that
from the internet for you for the
internet instead of instead of tv
infomercials they basically just do it
with like long-form blogs and then
long-form embedded videos so if you ever
like go down the rabbit hole like i've
tried to do it i've tried to figure out
like look at some of his brands they
hide their brands they hide them really
hard to find but when you do find one
you're like oh okay and then it's hard
to find where they advertising it's like
okay so they buy a display ad through
taboola on some random article and it's
for a toe cream
toe fungus removal and then you click
that and then you watch a 40 minute
video that auto plays with no pause or
skip button
and then by the end of that you're like
god damn like you know if you ended up
making it there you're almost certainly
going to buy this token then you
subscribe to the sms is and you get like
text messages from this legit doctor who
you know is the face of the brand it's
kind of like the the
the the um like rodan and fields is
another one which spun out of gun three
riker it's basically like two they
created proactive so i think it's two
dermatologists that created the formula
for proactive and then they left it
created rodan and fields which is a
multi-level marketing company that does
this that created their own they created
new formulations and this one they owned
a 100 i think that's a multi-billion
dollar company as well and if you're on
your computer listening to this one of
golden hippo's brands is called uh
gundry md i think dr steven gundry uh a
lot of people he's kind of famous i
think he's not famous in my world but i
think he's famous in like kind of
mainstream world actually
gundrymd.com is their website go to that
website and look at this website and it
they make it look like it's a small like
almost
thing first thing peak mobility plus
it's all about you mobility you love
mobile mobility and they even sell dog
food it's like it's it's a pretty wild
business and i think this is their most
popular brand
this brand if you told me does 100
million in sales i actually wouldn't be
surprised but if you didn't know better
you go to it you would have no idea
right and this is all about like gut
health plant-based you know plant-based
eating
uh stuff like that and so like you know
i get their text messages all the time
like don't you know don't get leaky gut
syndrome like buy this thing and uh
so you know it's very fascinating and
the reason i like bringing these up or
like what you brought up i think all the
companies you brought up today are cool
because
if you work in our our like most of our
friends who are like successful internet
entrepreneurs tech people silicon valley
executives at big tech companies they
will have never heard of any of this in
fact i did a breakdown of one of golden
hippos flows um and i sent it to all the
execs at twitch i go hey i went down the
rabbit hole of this like they laughed at
you they laughed at you they were just
like ha fascinating and they went back
to doing like you know spending millions
of dollars on facebook ads that just
said download twitch and it's like
okay like you know like is there any
creativity we could do here like to try
to like like i just showed you one of
the most creative things and like
nobody really cared nobody asked any
follow-up questions some people were
just like huh cool
to me
it was it's crazy to me and so like
so i feel like there's a lot you can
learn from from these kind of under the
radar brands or non-traditional and a
lot of people just write them off
they're like oh infomercial sleazy
affiliate marketing sleazy mlm sleazy
and like you may be right about like the
the sort of like that that these aren't
the best products that they're maybe the
best sold products but look i'm trying
to get great at sales so why would i not
look at the best sold products it's like
a no-brainer to me this was a good one i
think yeah i think it's a good one uh
this is definitely sort of like
unusual slash
potentially gray hat trust and untrust
trustworthy businesses um you know i
think i think it's gonna be entertaining
so yeah can we wrap up with well let me
wrap up first of all
gun three raker is amazing i would love
to see your notes on that if you can
share them um
also
i want to wrap up with one thing that
you on twitter you said you wouldn't
call me to invest in your company
because i'm risk adverse
you you said this and i want to explain
myself because that was a dig at me i
don't think you meant to be rude but i
took it as you being rude and i think
that
a lot of our friends call me this as
well you guys are so wrong i just don't
take dumb breath so here here's my
philosophy
listen here's my philosophy
i
so from age 20 i said by 30 i'm gonna
make enough money that i never have to
worry about money ever again you're not
and so that's when i started my company
many would say that was incredibly risky
i would say
compared to the average joe it was but
it wasn't that risky the reality it
wasn't that risky
then i got the money and i invest in
safe stuff
but here's the thing when i find [__]
that i love i go all in on it i just
what you and a lot of our friends do is
they go they go to they spread their
[__] like
wild i try to go all in on a couple of
things so i think i don't think i'm
risky a risk adverse i think that i just
pick and choose them differently yeah
that's true like okay let's say uh let's
say i'm starting a company uh and i
think i think i know what your answer
would be let's see if i was starting a
company and um
let's say i either didn't have an idea i
decided i'm gonna start a company or i
said it's gonna be in this space but i
don't know exactly what
or i said an idea that you're like i
don't even get that or that sounds kind
of dumb or fuzzy to me
um would you just invest then or would
you want to wait because you know i
would let you in at any point so you're
like you could well
i would ask one question
are you going all in and this is going
to be your only focus yeah if the answer
is if the answer is yes i would be like
i wouldn't raise money
i wouldn't even ask the valuation i
would just say okay so that's what i
think the answer is and that's kind of
the so the person asked a good question
i did a twitter kind of like i don't
know like an ama
um where i was like yo just shoot me
questions my wife took the kids out to
target i got an hour i want some
immediate
rush of twitter love let's just do some
q a and the person said you're raising
money for a company who you're who's the
first person you call and i i said all
right i said like here's my first five
phone calls and i basically name them
name them uh i don't really remember
what i said so i i'll tell you silly
silly ali i totally agree with that he's
an amazing operator very good investor
scott belski amazing investor good
signal to everyone
uh the third was uh
justin called back i think i had on
there
who's a i don't know him well but he's
an amazing investor
and then i had uh biology i think i had
on there they put both down okay obvious
reasons yeah pretty much then i had one
more person who else is on there i can't
find the tweet
i forget who that fifth person was as
well
but i i'm not offended that i didn't
make that list i'm offended that people
think that i'm risk adverse okay and and
i had a friend text me he goes do people
think you're risk adverse and i was like
oh i think they do but i think they're
like the first person i had was michael
burch the person who backed me with my
previous company so that yeah that would
be my first so here's my like
in reality you know i'm answering these
questions fast in reality i would
actually not
uh like two people who would uh two
people who i would not actually go to
first would not be scott belsky or
biology right because two reasons i
don't actually know them that well
they're not like my homies they're like
from you know like biology i consider
like yeah we're kind of friends but we
never like
hung out yeah we're cordial uh scott
belski same sort of thing like even even
even more distance actually and so like
you know respect but you know i can't
say this is like my homie and so in
reality my first five calls would be to
to like you sully michael birch
uh you know ramon like a bunch of our
like my true friends who i'm like hey
i'm doing something like yeah it's
basically like family exactly and so
that's like the true answer uh for
twitter you know i kind of like i didn't
want to put only people that people
would not like not recognize their names
you know
a couple people that they would know in
there um and there's also kind of
aspirational like who would i want to be
in my company i think scott belsey is an
amazing product person so i think that's
just like an amazing person to have on
there i think bollywood and he's like
the greatest and i mean he's one of the
best angel investors right so he's done
well and i think it's well connected so
i think that's useful to have and i
think uh
biology also is like a different kind of
signal so super obviously like hyper
intelligent
uh he comes from the future so that's
helpful in general and i think that um i
think that having him adds credibility
because if you only have your friends
there it doesn't help you get the next
investor on board necessarily because
they look at who else is invested and if
they don't see a name
that they recognize that they respect
that they don't it hasn't been like kind
of like they don't see the harvard stamp
of approval on there so you need that
mix in there so that's my justification
for it but yeah in reality i of course
would call you i know but you said i
don't care about that i care about oh
then i told other people that you're
risk-averse
i think that's crazy i think i put the
smiley face that means it's a joke the
smiley face means it's a joke
oh my god you think that i'm ready and
and to just i'm gonna wrap it up with
thomas scott belsky scott belski his
grandpa started kaplan
kaplan really no way i did not know that
yeah his grandpa started kaplan sold
that for like 80 or 100 million dollars
in like i think the 80s or 90s so it's
like you know that's like the equivalent
of like 300
then when he was 24 he invested fifteen
thousand dollars into pinterest when it
was worth three million dollars and
fifteen thousand dollars into uber when
it was worth three million dollars
he did this while he was running his
company called behance which was mostly
bootstrapped until like six months
before they sold it they raised a series
a but prior to that it was bootstrap and
when he sold it he owned i think 75 of
it he sold it for like 150 million
dollars
um and then so he made probably 100
million from the sale probably 100
million on uber and 100 million on
pinterest or give or take 50 percent and
now he's next in line to become ceo at
adobe
uh which is like the 40th largest
company in the world yeah total gangster
um
and good dude just fun fun hang which is
financially successful uh whenever i met
with him i met with him uh a while ago
and like he's like really good looking
he dresses really nice and he's like
[__] dreamy he's like so optimistic
and so happy and whenever he like talked
i was just like dude whatever you say
yeah he looks like the guy from maroon 5
adam levine exactly he looks like that
guy he's very good looking
and he's nice as hell he's really nice
yeah okay we should we should wrap it up
uh before we just totally you know
totally uh
i i heard gay for gay
foreign that would like be appropriate
to say my mind only went to uh dirty
words so i'm gay for belski i'm hardcore
gay for him i like him
all right we're out of here
[Music]
travel never looking back